Tomas you asked a very controversial
question the question is can we download
our consciousness into a chip and have
that chip being stored into a computer
and basically have our personalities
lasts forever we would be immortal well
first of all that raises a question who
are we anyway if I have a tape recorder
that has a little bit of intelligence
and it begins to answer questions the
way I would answer questions and i'm
sitting here with that tape recorder is
that really me what happens if that tape
recorder becomes increasingly more
sophisticated and can begin to pick up
nuances of my personality here i am i am
me but here i am sitting next to this
tape recorder which sounds like me has
all the interpretations and nuances of
me but it's not really me at all or is
it are we nothing but a bunch of neurons
with a certain programming in a certain
code well first of all you asked for a
timeline I personally think that this is
going to take a lot longer than we
expect simply because our brain
architecture and the way we deal with
situations is different from a digital
computer computers we have today are
digital they compute in zeros in one
they have subroutines they have
programming they have software they have
an operating system they have a CPU our
brain has none of these things our brain
has no cpu there's no programming
there's no windows software there are no
subroutines there's no programming at
all in our brain our brain is a learning
machine it encounters tasks and then
learns how to overcome these tasks one
by one so that's going to be the basic
problem simply digitalizing information
that's easy we can simply scan
information into a computer but you see
our brains learn we learn to adapt new
ideas we begin to learn new tasks and
new and new things and that's going to
be a lot more difficult to replicate by
computer so I personally don't think
we're going to see that in our lifetime
you